deschacht qui progressent lentement
photographiée hier au nord-est de kiev
les troupes russes en cercle peu à peu
la capitale
sur cette autre image au nord ouest ils
sont cachés dans les forêts de la ville
de loubianka en préparation d'une
offensive
il n'y a plus de convois long de 70 km
les chars sont déployés un peu partout
et évite les grands axes un changement
de tactique pour éviter ce qu'il s'est
passé hier dans la banlieue de kiev une
colonne de chars russes bombardé comme
on le voit sur ces vidéos diffusées par
un groupe nationaliste ukrainiens face
et russes
les ukrainiens lance des contre attaques
comme ici dans ce village de la banlieue
de kiev
les tirs sont nourris les troupes au
contact
dans les faubourgs de kiev ir pin est
devenue une ville fantôme jonchée de
défense anti char les combats se sont
poursuivis ces derniers jours ce soldat
recouvre un cadavre les derniers civils
tentent de fuir dans la panique je pense
que je tiens à dire que dans ma maison
des snipers sont assis et tiré en
direction de la maison de mon fils mon
fils unique
cette grand mère ukrainienne a plus rien
tout a été bombardé mais elle a fait le
choix de rester
nobody nos cordes ma maison a été
détruite par une bombe mais dans la
grange et quatre chèvres et dans le
grenier neuf chats et deux chiens mais
je n'ai nulle part où vivre il fait
froid c'est pourquoi je suis assise ici
elle vit désormais recluse dans cet abri
de fortune
réconforté par la seule présence de ces
animaux